why
so original sin issue number five is
going to bring an answer to a lot of
questions that we guys that we have one
of the most common questions being what
is the unseen what is that referring to
and how is it the Nick Fury ties into
all of this now in order to make this
video make sense I would highly suggest
that you guys go back and watch my
discussion on Nick Fury and the reason
why is because that video will give us
Nick Fury as he'd been presented by
Marvel Comics up until this point and so
what this video will do is fill in the
blanks it will tell us what Nick Fury
had been doing on the other side of that
video what he had been doing when he
wasn't appearing in Marvel Comics when
he wasn't a part of any major storyline
now what we see going on as the story
begins to take off is that Nick Fury is
starting immediately after his
discussion with the superheroes at the
end of original sin issue number four
and what he tells us is that in order to
make this make sense we have to go back
to 1958 in Kansas and what we see here
is that Nick Fury along with several
other soldiers is fighting some kind of
invading alien race they are breaking
into the planet Earth by way of a portal
for whatever their intentions or goals
happen to be now Nick Fury at this point
is part of Army Intelligence and so this
is shortly after a Nick Fury has been
introduced to us in the Marvel comics as
part of the military but again if you
recall our discussion about Nick Fury we
had talked about how there came a point
whereby Marvel was publishing two
instances Marvel was published in Nick
Fury or Publishing Nick Fury when he was
in world war ii but they were also
publishing his character when he was a
part of the CIA and this takes place in
between that what we see going on here
is that Nick Fury along with these
soldiers while they're fighting these
various aliens are doing the best they
can but for the most part they're almost
entirely outnumbered they're almost
entirely outmatched just due to the
technology at the disposal of these
various alien races in addition we see
some kind of an explosion when the
grenade goes off and what we see going
on here
is that as a result of this explosion
almost all of nick fury's team is killed
and the aliens are continuing to advance
out of their portal from here we see
that Nick Fury for the most part begins
to embrace the most likely possibility
that he will die that the planet Earth
will most likely be taken over by these
aliens and that there really won't be a
whole lot that anybody can do about it
Nick Fury tells us how during this time
they had fought various aliens here and
there they had fought different
organisms and whatnot but he had never
seen an alien invasion on this scale
before he was totally unprepared for it
but what we see is that at the last
minute an unknown individual appears and
begins destroying the forces of these
aliens in addition he began saying
things like the package has been
delivered and tells someone named Howard
to do it now we don't really know what
this means and we don't really know who
he's referring to or who this individual
is and for the most part in terms of his
name he's not extremely important but
what is important here is the rule that
he plays in the Marvel Universe what we
see here with Nick Fury's reaction is he
really doesn't know what to do he says
that if this individual is part of Army
Intelligence maybe or part of the Armed
Forces that he's way above Nick Fury's
pay grade in addition we see that as
this individual is fighting various
aliens that he is injured and when he's
injured the result is that he's injured
in a mortal way Nick Fury runs - aside
and realized that he's been impaled and
Nick Fury I tells him try not to move he
tells him to stay still the response
from this individual to Nick Fury is
that if Nick Fury is saying this then
most likely his injury is mortal Nick
Fury says that he's seen worse but this
individual replies by saying haven't
they all in addition this guy says that
he always thought it was going to be the
scrolls that would do him at naught this
unknown race of aliens and we see that
he begins to warn Nick Fury to tell Nick
Fury to watch out for the scrolls
because one day they were liable to do
something but before he's able to tell
him he begins to struggle and sort of
begin to succumb to his injuries in
addition what we also see Nick Fury
saying is that if this individual has
somebody to write to if he has somebody
that he wants to pass a letter to and he
should do it now and Nick Fury will
deliver that
for him but this individual says that
the only people that are waiting for him
are the people that he'll be seeing
almost immediately when he dies and
those are the people that will see him
in hell most presumably due to the
actions that he's committed or possibly
the the people that he's killed what we
also see going on is that the portal has
for the most part been totally destroyed
but on the other side of this portal is
some kind of again alien race and Nick
Fury begins to reflect on this Nick Fury
says that he didn't really know what to
do in this whole situation that he was
simply just sitting in Kansas in 1958
with a dead man in his arms staring in
an alien portal that had been totally
destroyed and didn't was really trying
to make sense of it all he said that you
know of course he saw a different alien
screaming and so on and that you know
while they were being killed that in the
end it was just strange that it was
something that he wasn't really wasn't
really used to that he wasn't really
able to deal with because he'd never
experienced anything like that before we
see that in the end this individual
succumbs to his injuries but then we see
that another unknown person runs up and
he says that the the bomb has been used
is going to make him make a small
fortune for him in addition he refers to
this unknown man as woody and this is
when we learned that this individuals
name is Woodward McCord or at least we
learned it later on and what we see
going on is that Nick Fury immediately
stands up and points a gun at this
unknown individual this on an individual
tells Nick Fury that he's a good guy
that he's not here to hurt anybody and
Nick Fury thinks that he begins to
recognize him but then we see this
unknown individual seize the body of
woody and he asks would he harasses Nick
Fury if woody is dead
Nick Fury says yes and as a result this
man introduces himself to Nick Fury what
he says is that his name is Howard Stark
and begins to say that he believes they
may have met before but before he can
say anything else Nick Fury cuts him off
and asks him who is this man that just
died to save the world in addition we
see that from here Nick Fury and Howard
Stark are traveling to some unknown
destination and Howard Stark begins
explaining what it is has been going on
what he tells Nick Fury here is that
this wasn't the first time that the
planets been invaded by aliens
he says that this is actually far from
the first time he says for every
encounter like the one that's been
experience for every encounter whereby
aliens are able to step foot on the
planet Earth there had been dozens more
whereby that had never happened where
the aliens had been destroyed before
they could ever arrive here and he said
he was all done by because of men like
woodrow McCord now what he says is that
would Woodrow McCord
is the man on the wall more or less that
he is the man that stands between
absolute destruction and the ability for
Humanity to continue existing now at the
moment we don't really know what this
means but what Howard Stark tells us
here is that inside this facility that
they've arrived at there are various
forms of Technology here this facility
actually appears to be quite advanced
and he tells Nick Fury that this is the
domain of the man on the wall and that
the man on the wall doesn't answer to
anybody the man on the wall does not
answer to any kind of authority group he
doesn't answer to any kind of federal
government or any kind of national
government that he answers only to the
people of the planet Earth and that his
only mission is only role is to ensure
that any kind of a force whether
internal from the planet Earth itself or
external beyond the planet earth or even
extra-dimensional does not succeed in
bringing it into a life or bring it and
into life on the planet Earth and so
what he asked Nick Fury is whether or
not he would be interested in becoming
the new man on the wall to take the role
of Woodrow McCord what we see here is
that Nick Fury takes his assignment
without question Nick Fury accepts it
without any kind of regard and decides
to accept the offer of being the man on
the wall and what Nick Fury tells us
here is that for him he'd always been a
soldier in a spy at least as far as he
could remember and so for him this was
pretty much the same thing he was simply
just on a much bigger scale in addition
we see that the time eventually comes
when Nick Fury becomes the director of
shield and what he tells us here is that
while he was the director of shield that
his role as the man on the wall was
still a part of his life this was
something that he still had going on and
so again this is something that Nick
Fury had been doing the entire time
that he had been in existence in Marvel
Comics after the events of World War two
and so this is something that Marvel had
never told us this is something that
Marvel had never explained to us
directly in addition what we also see is
that Nick Fury is using life model
decoys which is an indication to us that
Nick Fury of course as far as his first
encounters with the scrolls go is most
likely an event that took place between
the Kree squirrel invasion and the
events of Nick Fury versus shield now
whether or not this means that the most
likely scenario here is that one came
before the other this is something that
we're not entirely sure of because in a
lot of ways Marvel is sort of bad when
it comes to chronology in terms of
establishing dates we really kind of
have to piece it together we have to
make sense of it on our own especially
when you're when you're dealing with
sliding timescales and the actions of
characters like Franklin Richards and so
on but what we learn here is that Nick
Fury is interrogating a scroll and Nick
Fury is attempting to gain some kind of
information from it now we don't really
know why but what we see here is that
Nick Fury is presumably trying to attain
whatever it is that he needs by using
physical force in order to to force this
information out of this scroll from here
we transition to New York City then what
we learn here is that Nick Fury is again
fulfilling his role as the man on the
wall and observing a possible threat in
some being that has appeared and is a
radioactive being that could most likely
cause a multitude of different kinds of
havoc or could at the very least become
a danger to life on the planet Earth but
what we see here is that Nick Fury while
he's now using gamma bomb bullets while
he's now using bullets that are modeled
after Bruce banners gamma bomb
experiment has a change of heart and
decides not to shoot this individual and
what we learn here is that this
individual is in fact spider-man
indicating to us that Nick 3 was doing
this around the time the spider-man
first appeared in Marvel Comics which
again gives us this sort of strange
explanation gives us this sort of a
strange timescale we're not really sure
if this explanation is Nick Fury is
giving it to us is going in a
chronological order or if you simply
just kind of ban
around all over the place from here we
see that Nick Fury is explaining to us
this entire concept of what it means to
be the man on the wall and Nick Fury is
telling us that for every single
conflict that it ever happened for every
event that had ever taken place
involving the planet Earth this has
simply happened because Nick Fury wasn't
able to stop it that the secret invasion
that the kree-skrull war the arrival of
Galactus and the Silver Surfer the very
first instance of a space bound
character having being affordable enough
of a threat to the planet Earth
the instances of the maximum security
storyline whereby Ron and the accuser is
the ruler of the planet Earth as it's
turned into a prison planet these had
all taken place because Nick Fury wasn't
able to stop that threat but that for
every single one of these events that
had happened there had been dozens that
had gone on here there have been dozens
of instances whereby this had taken
place where these threats had been
destroyed before they could actually
reach the planet Earth before they could
reach their maturity in addition what we
see here is that while Nick Fury tells
us that Howard Stark and various other
individuals almost anybody who knew that
he was the man on the wall had long
since been dead that while he believed
he was the only person who actually knew
everything that was going on but there
was one other person who had seen
everything and that person was watching
The Watcher which tells us that this is
the unseen this is what Marvel's
referring to when they say the unseen
and the reason why it's called the
unseen astound superheroes or even
anybody else in the universe aside from
The Watcher knew what was going on but
also because we as the reader didn't
know what was going on we had no idea
that any of this was taking place and so
for us it was unseen it would be
something that we were entirely unaware
of from here we transitioned back to
Nick Fury in the current time and Nick
Fury tells the superheroes that's why
they're here he tells them that this is
the reason why they've all arrived in
this place and he asked them if they
have any questions what we see is these
superheroes dealing with them in their
own way dealing with this news and the
best way they know how we see that dr.
strange says that this doesn't make
sense that when Nick Fury is confessing
to can't be
because this isn't the Nick Fury that he
knows but the question that has to be
asked here is has Doctor Strange ever
actually dealt with the real Nick theory
or is every instance where he's met Nick
Fury been Nick Fury using a life model
decoy has it been Nick Fury simply
hiding in on a satellite near the moon
and dr. strange and various other
superheroes all talking to life model
decoys which seems to be the case it
seems to be that ever since the
introduction of life model decoys and
the Marvel Comics that no one has ever
actually talked to Nick Fury that
everybody has been communicating with
life model decoys all this time but
again this is some of the Marvel doesn't
really go into a deep explanation about
what we see here is of course the
Punisher saying he doesn't see a problem
with it but then we also see the orb
telling us that Nick Fury isn't
explaining everything but before he can
get to what it is at Nick Fury is not
explaining he begins to succumb to the
expanse knowledge that he had gained by
manipulating the eyes of the watcher and
so as a result he goes into shock from
here we transitioned to the remaining
superheroes beginning to again try to
absorb this information try to absorb
what's been going on here and black
panther speaks up and says that he has a
question for Nick theory then what he
asks him is what happened to the watcher
Nick Fury replies here by simply saying
that the watcher died and that now he
supposes his turn with that being said
this brings an end to original send
issue number five and what we'll see
with issue number six is this
continuation of this story we'll find
out there's actually a lot more going on
here than we were initially led to
believe and that Nick Fury despite the
fact that he pretends as though he's not
really sure what's going on with the
watcher that he actually has quite a bit
of knowledge in terms of what it was
that happened with the watcher with that
being said I will catch you guys later
peace